hello everyone welcome to the line
focused channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the Dutch language
Dutch is a language that spoken mainly
in Europe but also in a few other places
around the world
it has 23 million native speakers and
around 28 million speakers in total
including second language speakers it is
most widely spoken in the Netherlands
where it has around 16 million native
speakers it is also spoken by around 60%
of the population of Belgium mostly in
the northern region of Flanders that's
around 6.5 million people it's also
spoken by a small number of people
across the border in French Flanders
which lies adjacent to Belgium but only
around 20,000 people there still speak
it on a regular basis it is also spoken
in the South American nation of Suriname
where it has around 350,000 native
speakers as well as around 250,000
second language speakers it is also an
official language on the island of Aruba
along with the language papiamento but
few of the hundred thousand people there
actually used Dutch even though they all
learn it in school it is also spoken in
Curacao where it is spoken by around
15,000 people as a native language and
by many of the other 140,000 people as a
second language it is also an official
language in Sint Maarten along with
English a couple of thousand people
there speak Dutch but English is
actually much more common
there is also Afrikaans a language
spoken in South Africa and Namibia which
is a dotter language of Dutch and is
mutually intelligible to some extent but
I'll leave Afrikaans out for now and
I'll speak about it in a different video
in the future Dutch is a member of the
West Germanic branch of the Germanic
language family which also includes
Afrikaans Frisian English and German
among others
Dutch is one of the languages that is
most closely related to English actually
Frisian is more closely related to
English than Dutchess but Dutch is a
close second and a lot of people say
that Dutch is quite similar to German
too in fact some people say that Dutch
lies somewhere between English and
German now that's not a very precise
statement but I think there is some
truth to it the history of Dutch all
Germanic languages developed from
proto-germanic which was spoken around
500 BCE in northern continental Europe
and also in Scandinavia by the 2nd
century CE II it had begun diverging in
two distinct northern Western and
Eastern dialects the Western dialect is
the ancestor of Dutch and of all of the
West Germanic line
variation developed in the Western
dialects but all of its varieties
remained intelligible until around the
8th century CE but by then a series of
sound changes had begun to take place
that made old high german
the ancestor of modern german much more
distinct from the other west germanic
languages for more information on german
and its history check out my video on
german right here old Dutch also known
as old low Franconian remained
unaffected by the changes that affected
old high german also unaffected were old
saxon old frisian and old english but
those languages underwent a different
series of sound changes but again Dutch
was mostly unaffected by these changes
to middle Dutch old Dutch developed into
middle Dutch which was spoken and
written between 1150 and 1500 C it was a
rich literary period and literature from
this time period is often quite readable
for speakers of modern Dutch because
Dutch is quite a conservative language
middle Dutch developed into modern Dutch
by the middle of the 16th century the
process of the standardization of Dutch
began in the year fourteen seventy seven
at the end of the middle Dutch period
the dialects of Flanders and Brabant
were most influential at that time then
in the sixteenth century
the move to standardization became
stronger with the Antwerp dialect being
the most influential in the Year 1637
the first major Dutch Bible translation
known as stout and fair italic had been
published it had been translated in such
a way that people from all over the
country could read and understand it
this Bible was read by nearly everyone
and it helped greatly in the
standardization of Dutch the southern
Netherlands now Belgium and Luxembourg
were separate and under Spanish Austrian
and then French rule more than half of
the people in Belgium spoke a dialect of
Dutch but French was most widely used in
public life in schools etc so Dutch
remained unstandardized there until the
19th century when the Flemish movement
started standing up for the rights of
Dutch speakers they adopted the same
standard language used in the
Netherlands nowadays in both the
Netherlands and in Flanders the northern
Dutch speaking region of Belgium the
situation is similar there are a number
of spoken varieties of Dutch as well as
a standard language so the difference
lies mainly in pronunciation of standard
Dutch and in the local dialects used the
dialects of Flanders tend to be more
conservative and use more older Dutch
vocabulary regional languages there are
dialect but there are also different
regional languages that are West
Germanic languages and closely related
to Dutch but not as closely related as
the dialects that are considered part of
Dutch regional languages in the
Netherlands include Frisian in the
northern province of Friesland low saxon
in the northeast and there are various
dialects of low Saxon and limburgish or
east low Franconian in the southeast low
saxon spreads across the border with
Germany and forms part of a dialect
continuum between Dutch and German if
you've seen my German video you know
that the dialects in northern Germany
are referred to as low German and can be
considered a separate language the Dutch
low Saxon dialects are closely related
to the low German dialects across the
border this is also true for limburgish
which is related to franconi and
dialects spoken across the border in
germany it should be noted that Dutch
dialects and regional languages are in
decline with standard Dutch becoming
more widespread and with some people
speaking a kind of combination of
standard Dutch with some dialectal
features so what is Dutch like Dutch is
not mutually intelligible with English
but you will often notice cognate
vocabulary and at the most basic level
you will notice similar grammar if you
disregard the details and just look at
the most basic sentences occasionally
there are sentences in Dutch that might
be strangely familiar to English
speakers for example but this yo Nam
this means what is your name my name is
Luke this means my name is Luke the bass
drunk beat
this one means the bear drank beer I
think I must have gotten that one from
duolingo at this neat fish this means it
is not far thought this would news this
means that is good news
now if all dutch sentences were so
similar to english then the two
languages could probably be quite
intelligible with each other but most
dutch sentences are not that similar to
english but you will see a lot of
cognate vocabulary grammar similar to
German Dutch is a language that places
verbs at the end of the sentence after
the first initial verb so its underlying
structure is basically sov but the first
verb is in second position after the
subject so if there's only one verb in
the sentence then it's basically like
SVO here's a sentence with one verb
except in belief this means I am writing
a letter word by word this is like I
write a letter just like English with
the verb in second position here's a
sentence with two verbs ich v OE of of
liquor haven this means I want to give
you some goodies word by word that's I
want you in direct object some goodies
give in the sentence the first verb is
in second position but the next verb
comes at the end of the sentence nouns
gender when it comes to gender Dutch
traditionally has three genders
masculine feminine and neuter but in
modern spoken Dutch the distinction
between masculine and feminine gender
has almost become irrelevant because
they don't look or sound different it
used to determine which pronoun would be
used to refer to those nouns whether
it's he or she but people generally just
use he these days so now the two genders
are basically common gender and neuter
the nouns gender agrees with articles as
well as the forms of adjectives plural
there are two types of plural endings in
Dutch one is en and the other is s there
are some well not rules but patterns for
when to use each one but there are a lot
of exceptions so you have words like
dirt dirt and votes Horton and you have
words like little slough Tolls label
labels a few neuter nouns have a plural
form Aaron for example Gynt kinderen
cases Dutch used to have noun cases
similar to German there were four cases
nominative genitive dative and
accusative these were part of standard
written Dutch until the 1940s but they
were dropped because nobody used them in
speech anymore there are several
different articles in Dutch there is an
indefinite article and there are
definite articles for singular and for
plural nouns for singular masculine the
for singular feminine the for singular
neuter head and the definite article for
plural for all genders the an
interesting thing is there is a negative
article saying this is the same for all
genders and for both singular and plural
verbs there are two verb tenses in Dutch
past and present or non past but saying
there are two tenses is kind of
misleading because similar to an English
the verb can be used in combination with
different auxiliary verbs to express
different meanings and there are
participle forms that can be used to
show passive or continuous actions for
example here's a sentence using the
simple past at Bowdoin Hirsch this means
he built a house so we start with the
infinitive volun and this is the verb
stem and this is the past 10
form bode now here's a present perfect
sentence
hey Hilton Hershiser boats this means he
has built a house so we start with the
infinitive heaven and here's the verb
stem and here's the past tense leaves
and the second verb is a past participle
this is formed by adding the prefix GE
and the suffix D notice again that the
second verb is at the end of the
sentence even though the first verb is
in second position after the subject
there are three different ways to
express the future tense one of them is
to use this auxiliary verb julen this
means something like shall or will Excel
had more hundun this sentence means I
will do it tomorrow you can also use
this verb meaning to go plus the
infinitive this is similar to using
going to in English for example
headcrab - and this means it's going to
rain and you can also use the present
tense for the future is a common post
lat
this means they won't come until later
literally they come only later
so the verb system in Dutch is rather
similar to the one used in English the
main difference being that any verb
after the first one comes at the end
pronunciation one of the hardest parts
of learning Dutch might be the
pronunciation because there are some
sounds that can be a challenge for
learners and native speakers of Dutch
seem quite conscious of the challenges
we face that was kind of an indirect way
of saying they think our pronunciation
sucks some of the sounds that require
special effort are the Dutch G sound for
example note and the sound which CH
often represents for example Johan
notice that this is the same sound as
the one represented by G but in other
cases CH represents the shook sound now
sometimes those sounds come at the
beginning of a word which is a little
bit of a challenge but sometimes they
come right after the letter S like in
the word for school so this sound
combination is quite common in Dutch
there are a lot of long words in Dutch
some of them can be over 30 characters
long here are a couple extreme examples
Myhrvold have persona kites tourneys
this one means multiple personality
disorder and that is 35 characters long
in the carnival's abduct for breading
sphere exam Hayden plum this one means
preparation activities for a children's
carnival procession and this is 53
characters long and Dutch also has a lot
of colorful idioms for example mom
God's wish this means make the cat wise
this means that someone is saying
something so I would land ashore
unbelievable that even the cat won't
believe it another example a hastened
bust in to kill this means he has a
beard in his throat this idiom describes
a situation when a boy reaches puberty
and his voice starts to change how hard
is Dutch to learn for English speakers a
lot of Dutch will seem strangely
familiar and of course that will help
but there are some issues in learning
the pronunciation as well as the finer
details of grammar but maybe the hardest
thing about learning Dutch is that Dutch
speakers usually speak English very well
so it will be hard to practice when you
try to speak Dutch with people they'll
probably answer you in English but you
can solve that problem by taking some
lessons or doing a language exchange and
practicing on your own until you reach a
fairly good level and have a fairly good
base then after that you can speak to
people in Dutch without totally pissing
them off the question of the day for
native speakers of Dutch how well can
you understand the speakers of regional
languages that are related to Dutch
languages like Frisian or low Saxon and
for people who have studied Dutch what
was your experience with trying to learn
and practice Dutch how did people
respond to you did they answer you in
English what was the best way for you to
learn and practice Dutch leave your
answers and your comments down below be
sure to follow Lange focus on Twitter on
Facebook and on Instagram and thanks
again to all of my patreon supporters
for your wonderful contributions every
month thank you for watching and have a
nice day
[Music]